as the Foreign Affairs columnist for The
New York Times Thomas Friedman won the
2001 Pulitzer Prize for commentary next
mr. Friedman discusses his new book a
collection of newspaper columns about
September 11th and the aftermath it's an
hour and 15 minutes hi everyone it's
good to see everybody welcome to
everybody and especially to Tom Friedman
I'm Karla Koh and I'm co-owner of
politics and prose and I want Tom
Friedman is our special friend
he has celebrated all of the books that
he has published at politics and prose
and somehow when he is he comes it's it
marks the significant occasion in our
existence usually that we're expanding
and as you can see we need that again
and when we expand I hope that we'll
have more chairs and even if we everyone
can't see at least there'll be a way of
more people being able to sit down Tom
Friedman has a special way of making
naughty world problems understandable
and immediate his humor well we all
remember his line six years ago I think
it was about Netanyahu he said he is
deeply deeply shallow
now and even more perilous times we have
a president who can be described that
way I thought about that line very very
often this past year Tom Friedman is our
voice in the national dialogue he stands
for peace and moderation and
democratization you loved his book his
collected column some predating the
horrible event of a year ago and most
written since our models reason and his
journal which he kept traveling is
compelling
welcome again Tom Friedman Thank You
Carla it's a it's a treat to be back
here I have fond memories of being in
the old store for Beirut to Jerusalem
back here for Lexus and the olive tree I
didn't think I'd be back quite so soon
with another book I was as some of you
may know I my publisher asked me after
Lexus um if I would write a new book and
I told him yes I wanted to do a book on
golf and he said the Persian Gulf and I
said no that was not what I had in mind
but this certainly wasn't a book I had
in mind 13 months ago but it was the
book I felt I had to write and I'm glad
I did and I hope you enjoy it I thank
you all for coming out and I really
thank all of those who are standing I
know it's not comfortable I really
appreciate your being here and I hope
that I can make it an interesting
evening I'm going to talk for the next
20 minutes or so just to try to address
some of the most oft asked questions
I've gotten since 9/11 and questions
normally that have come from people but
that I've asked myself and hopefully use
those as a trigger to lead off a
discussion I think the most most oft
asked question
that I've asked myself since 9/11 is who
were those guys who were those 19
hijackers who aborted those planes
almost a year ago now and flew them into
the World Trade Center the Pentagon in a
field in Pennsylvania and I've asked
myself that question not only out of
curiosity but out of anger and out of a
desire or a feeling that if we don't
know who these people were if we don't
understand fully what motivated them we
can't begin to really tackle this
problem and so that's been a theme that
I've really been on from the very
beginning now what I basically concluded
is that the hijackers these 19 guys fall
into two categories one category I call
the Saudis and the other category I call
the Europeans there are really two
distinct categories there and let me
explain to you on what I mean by the two
the Saudis were what I would call the
muscle guys the guys who were in the
back of the plane who his job was to
restrain the passengers guys who were
really not instrumental to the plot and
were only brought in according to a bin
Laden himself at the last minute without
really knowing much other than that they
were involved in a martyrdom operation
as he said I call them the Saudis
because virtually all of them came from
Saudi Arabia from Saudi Arabia's osteo
province which is in the southwest
corner just north of Yemen in fact most
of them came from they all lived on
roughly the same highway down there and
they are part of a group of a young
generation of Saudi males that I would
call to sit and around guys because
there's there are a lot of young men
they're sitting around on these young
men were came from middle to
upper-middle class families in many
cases they were the first to be educated
through high school or college they a
lot of them initially sort of entered
the fold of of al-qaeda
I be recruited for the war in
Afghanistan against the Soviet Union
when that war was over they came back to
Saudi Arabia it seems that there was
more sitting around more going to
radical mosque where they were exposed
to radical preachers and somewhere along
the way they were in Osama bin Laden's
rolodex and when the time came for the
operation
they were tapped on the shoulder and
recruited and they came what produced
them the the kind of engine that
produced them is what I call the wheel
of bin Laden ISM and the wheel of bin
Laden ISM is made of three basic parts
the first part is autocratic
anti-democratic authoritarian regimes
which really predominate today in the
Arab Muslim world we had an Arab League
summit a couple months ago 22 nations
represented not a single one represented
by a leader elected in a free and fair
election there is no region in the world
where you could have a regional summit
and not a single leader there was
elected in a free and fair election not
sub-saharan Africa not Latin America not
anywhere and this unfortunately is
really the dominant political mode in
that space for Morocco to the border of
India so the top of the wheel are these
anti-democratic authoritarian regimes in
order to gain legitimacy these regimes
in the absence of elections basically
empower or strike a bargain with what I
would call anti-modernist religious
leaders and educators and it's a very
simple transaction the anti-modernist
religious leaders and educators bless
the regime as it were and the regime
blesses them with the imprimatur of the
government as the official spiritual
leaders and provides them with cash to
operate
well these anti-modernist religious
leaders in turn dominate an education
system which produces young people who
in many cases are not prepared
basically to deal with the modern world
that produces poverty and the wheel
really just goes around and around the
anti Democrat
regime's reinforced the anti-modernist
religious educators the anti-modernist
religious educators reinforced the
anti-modernist religious education the
anti-modernist education produces young
people unprepared for modernity that
produces poverty it reinforces the
autocracy and the wheel just goes around
and around and it spins off thousands
upon thousands of sitting around guys
who really aren't prepared for the
modern world and are prey to radical
preachers who tell them that all the
problems in the world come from America
that's the thought woody guys that's the
rough profile I would draw them the
really interesting characters though I
would argue are what I call the
Europeans Europeans are Muhammad Atta
and the key pilots and plotters the guy
who's really drove the plot the Hamburg
cell the guys who were studying at the
harburg Hamburg Technical College and
were part of that cell there what you
notice if you look at the biographies of
these guys and if you look in fact at
the biographies of every other one of
the terrorists who have been exposed
since 9/11 something jumps out at you
and what jumps what jumped out at me is
the fact that not a single one of them
left home left Egypt or Saudi Arabia or
Morocco or Tunisia not a single one of
them left home a Muslim radical every
one of them was converted to radical
Islam in Europe in their encounter with
the West and it is there where the spark
the cognitive dissonance cognitive
dissonance excuse me for their
radicalism was really struck I say not
only true of the 9/11 hijackers a mr.
Shah the Pakistani who murdered Danny
Pearl converted in England
Moussaoui the gentleman who went out to
Minnesota to try to learn how to fly a
747 but wasn't interested in learning
how to land
converted he's a Tunisian son of
Tunisian mother converted to radical
Islam in France mr. read the bozo
couldn't blow up his own tennis shoes
converted to radical Islam in a British
prison the two guys who assassinated
Shah Massoud two Tunisians converted to
radical Islam in Belgium every one of
these guys was converted to radical
Islam in their encounter with Europe now
what's all that about I think a lot of
factors go into it the first is the fact
that Europe is not a melting pot people
can criticize America for not being a
good melting pot or a warm enough
melting pot but I think we do a pretty
good job a Europe does not aspire to be
a melting pot and these young men come
to these European countries and they
find themselves really alienated and
often shoved out and drifting to the
edges of society they gathered together
as this group did at Hamburg University
into prayer groups for warmth and
solidarity which is perfectly
understandable some then gravitate to
more radical prayer groups and some
gravitate to still more radical prayer
groups what also fuels them is the fact
that Egypt Saudi Arabia a lot of these
countries have evicted their most
intense Muslim radical preachers to
Europe where they have found a refuge
and been given political refuge by
governments there under the guise of
being accorded political asylum so you
have there both the raw material of
alienated young men and you have the
preachers but there is I think a larger
story here and I try to frame it in the
book in computer terms because I think
it really gets to the core of the
cognitive dissonance that really
afflicted these young men as people have
read Lexus in the olive tree know I tend
to like to put things in computer terms
so I'm going to put this in computer
terms Islam's self-identity and I mean
no insult and no insult should be taken
from this
but Islam's self-identity is that it is
the most complete um an ideal version of
monotheism if sees Muhammad the Prophet
Muhammad as the seal of the prophets and
it sees Islam as the completion of the
monotheistic Creed which was begun with
Judaism through Christianity but
completed in its fullest and most ideal
form in the Quran it sees itself I would
argue as God 3.0 and these young men are
raised in a world where they are
nurtured on the idea that Islam is God
3.0 it sees Christianity as God 2.0 and
it sees Judaism as God 1.0 now the
cognitive dissonance happens and the
reason it happens in Europe is because
these young men come to Europe imbued
with and raised on the notion of Islam
as God 3.0 and they discover and have to
face the reality that got 2.0 and God
1.0 are living so much more prosperously
so much more powerfully so much more
democratically than God 3.0 and that's
really where the spark happens because
somebody has to explain that and the
person who explained it was Osama bin
Laden and people like him and the way
they explained it was very simple they
explained it in two ways one was that
God 1.0 and God 2.0 got together and did
something to God 3.0 got together and
took something away from God 3.0 that
was one explanation another explanation
is that the leaders who should be
directing God 3.0 have drifted away from
the authentic version and corrupted and
corroded it those are the explanations
of course there is another explanation
and the other explanation is that God
2.0 isn't really God 2.0 it's actually
got 2.0 point 1 it's the reformed
and enlightened version it's
Christianity that's gone through the
laundromat of the Enlightenment and
Reformation separating church from state
and interpreting its face in a way that
can embrace modernity and God 1.0 is not
really God wonderful I know if actually
today got one point 0.1 it's a Judaism
that's gone through the Enlightenment
and Reformation separating synagogue
from state and reinterpreting its faith
for many Jews to embrace modernity until
there is a God three point 0.1 there's
going to be a problem until there is an
Islam that has been interpreted in terms
of its own text and by his own faith
adherents and by his own spiritual
leaders in a way that can separate
mosque from state and embrace modernity
this cognitive dissonance is going to be
there and so to me that's really where
the spark of 9/11 comes from and why all
of these radicals were minted not at
home but in the middle of the West
now the conditions the second question
might then be you know what are the
conditions under which one could imagine
a god 3.2.1 being articulated and and
here we get to the issue of why I have
been such a strong advocate of democracy
and democratization in the Arab and
Muslim world all over the world for that
matter
um and it's because a lot of people will
say to me geez Islam is a really angry
religion to which I say no I don't think
that's true but I think there are a lot
of Muslims who are angry I think that's
what's true and I think a lot of Muslims
are angry because they live in countries
where they have no voice in their
government have no voice in their future
they live under corrupt dictatorial
regimes it's a very interesting thing
you know that I've learned myself and my
travels it's a very simple thing but
context matters the context within which
people live their life really matters
and what is religion but a mirror on the
context of your life you know what's the
second largest Muslim country in the
world you know trick question
most people don't get it it's called
India
India which has 150 million Muslims
obviously up in roughly a million Hindus
but has the second largest Muslim
population in the world and Indian
Muslims have issues they have economic
grievances there have been occasional
outbursts as we saw in Gujarat earlier
this year attacking Indian Muslims by
Hindu nationalists they have political
issues of discrimination but I asked
myself why wasn't there a single Indian
Muslim in al-qaeda does it have to do
with the fact maybe that the president
of India today is a Muslim does it have
to do with the fact that the richest man
in India today is a Muslim software
engineer the founder of Infosys
does it have to do with the fact that
the context within which Indian Muslims
live and plan their lives and achieve
their goals is a democratic context that
is basically open to them context really
matters and the reason it's related to
this religious question is just in India
a few weeks ago you know there's only
one mosque I know of in the world where
Muslim women have demanded the right to
pray alongside men in the mosque which
isn't allowed you know where that was it
was in Hyderabad India and you know why
that was because women in a democratic
context feel empowered and protected to
raise these issues you know in the first
week of the war of Afghanistan the one
of the Muslim leaders in India called an
Indian Muslims to join the jihad against
the United States and one of the most
popular film stars in India is an Indian
Muslim woman I forgot her name right now
maybe someone here knows and she in a
debate carried live on Indian TV told
this guy basically you want to fight in
Afghanistan you go you go okay but I'm
not going and we shouldn't go because
this isn't our fight I mean that's what
you get in a democratic context women
feel empowered to raise these issues but
not only women people who want to raise
these theologic
questions are protected and empowered to
do that the Reformation happened when
princes in Germany were ready to protect
the Reformers Martin Luther and his life
from the papacy if you don't create the
political space for a Reformation it's
not going to happen so democracy is
really important now the next question I
often get from people is um well yeah
freedom you know but if you have
democracy if Saudi Arabia
do you realize what will happen they
will be spewing out hate against America
in their press and from their mosques
and they will teach hate against
infidels in their schools and they will
spawn terrorism to which I say good
morning Mary sunshine what do we have
now okay what do we have now but just
that we have a factory for that I want
the Islamists to get elected in Saudi
Arabia I want them to be responsible and
I want them to have to be responsible
for their own radicalism in front of
their own people I want them to have to
look their people in the eye and say
folks we're not going to sell any oil
any more to the infidels because they're
bad now that does mean there'll be no
Disney World this year and there'll be
no University of Texas and there'll be
no trip to the United States and
there'll be no trip to Lebanon and your
income is going to be cut in half I want
them to have to be responsible for their
own radicalism in front of their own
people
because only then will you get the war
within the war of ideas within by them
we can raise the questions but only they
can answer them and the great place
where that war is now going on the
Muslim country the only Muslim country
where people spontaneously went into the
streets on a candlelight vigil in the
week after September 11th was Iran okay
and that is not an accident because
Iranian said enough democracy now - no
they want more of it and they've had
enough Islam crammed down their throat
by crackpot mullahs - no they want less
of it and what is going on today in Iran
is a terrific experiment and struggle of
Iranians trying to find a balance
between Islam and
ah cracy and god bless them because if
they can find that balance if they can
find that balance the impact it's going
to have on the whole Muslim world will
be a hundred times greater than the
Iranian Revolution ever was and we
should be careful as we think about Iraq
because if you follow what happened in
Iran last week something very important
president hot to me reflecting this I
was just in Iran two months ago
reflecting this feeling from the people
basically told the conservative
hardliners there who are keeping
everyone down I'm mad as hell and I'm
not going to take it anymore and we have
to be careful that if we go into Iraq
now the Conservatives and hardliners
there don't use that as an excuse to
abort this whole process because what's
going on in Iran today is tremendously
important we cannot move it along any
faster there's nothing we can do it has
to go at its own space and its own pace
in its own way we can raise the
questions but only they can answer them
and they're only going to be answered in
a democratic context so those are a few
of the questions that early questions I
had another question I often get
obviously is what do we do what can we
do in terms of simply confronting these
sort of issues and um here I say we have
to do two things I'm one is we have to
kill Osama bin Laden I know that sounds
you know sometimes politically incorrect
and whatnot just people often say
violence doesn't solve anything and
actually that's not true
okay because um you know violence you
know that is indiscriminate and violence
that is misdirected and violence that is
feckless doesn't solve anything but
violence that is directed against people
want to kill you for who you are not
what you do solves a lot okay and we
should have no illusions about that all
right we need to send two very important
messages one is that you send 3,000 you
send 19 young men over here to kill
3,000 of our people we will track you
down if we have to look in every cave in
Tora Bora
find you okay because justice will be
served that deterrent message has to go
forward
you cannot come over here to our country
and do that and they'll go back home and
sip Turkish coffee and make videos
chortling about it we will track you
down that is important and the second
reason the second reason it's important
okay is that these particular terrorists
bin Laden and his crew they were they
were in my view the Michael Jordan and
Chicago Bulls of terrorism okay they
were really a unique and a uniquely
dangerous group bin Laden combined two
things which I've never seen before in
the terrorists he was a combination of
Charles Manson and Jack Welch very
unusual okay very unusual the most
mendacious and evil sort of mind
combined with the corporate and
organizational skills of a fortune 500
manager guys like him don't come along
every day okay and what has been
accomplished by either driving these
guys underground and paralyzing them or
hopefully having eliminated them is that
we have bought a lot of time here and
the last year is evidence of that we
have defeated we've wiped out Michael
Jordan and the Chicago Bulls now now
we're dealing with the bench and the CBA
okay and that's what we're dealing with
with mr. Reid a guy who couldn't figure
out how to light his own tennis shoes
showed up for a flight with no luggage
having not shaved in six days and saying
I'd like a one-way ticket to America
that's what you get when you go down
just one rung okay there's a big gap
between these guys now the thing you
have to understand about Al Qaeda I
believe is that if you want to
understand al Qaeda don't think IBM
don't think flow chart with headquarters
here and you know all this stuff out
there think McDonald's okay think
franchises this is a franchise operation
we have wiped out the central
headquarters we've wiped out Ray Kroc
and the corporate headquarters in San
Diego but
there are still a lot of franchises
operating out there but none of them
have quite the skill the resources
audacity and imagination yet that bin
Laden and his crew had so I think it's
very important to take these people on
it's more important to kill their ideas
much more important at the end of the
day that's really what will make us safe
and that's to take on their ideas now
there are things that we can do to make
that easier and I think we should be
doing everything we can do to create an
international environment where the
regime's in which these people reside
and are raised are ready to take on
their ideas I think we should be as
energetic as we possibly can in trying
to bring a peaceful resolution to the
israeli-palestinian conflict much more
energetic than this regime has been I
think we have to stop telling the world
either you're with us or against us in
the war on terrorism but in the war
against global warming and making this a
greener planet
well sorry we've got better things to do
we'd like to consume as much energy as
we please thank you very much if we're
going to have the world with us in a war
on terrorism where we stomp around from
Manila to Afghanistan to Manhattan we
have to be the best global citizens we
can be and we're not going to have
allies in this video we have to do thank
you we have to do everything we can to
create an environment in which people
will want to take on these ideas and
where we will take away excuses from
them for not taking on these ideas but
at the end of the day they have to take
on the bin Laden ISM and here there's
been just an enormous failure since 9/11
because the thing you have to understand
about bin Laden is that he's an
authentic character as hateful you know
as I think years as a person bin Laden
is an authentic character all right he
came from one the richest non-royal
family in Saudi Arabia he gave up the
life of a multi-millionaire in Saudi
Arabia to go off to Afghanistan and live
in a cave and fight the Soviet Union and
help drive it out of Afghanistan
unfortunately he got twisted
after that and turned his energy against
the United States but he's an authentic
character and you only defeat that kind
of authenticity with another
authenticity bin-laden
articulated an authentic Arab Islamic
retrograde vision and it can only be
defeated with an authentic Islamic
progressive vision and that's what
totally has not happened since 9/11 the
pattern of these regimes basically is to
expel their Islamists to export them to
the West or put them in jail but it's
never to take on their ideas and the
reason they don't articulate a Arab
authentic progressive message is because
very few of them are authentic Islamic
progressives none of the leaders in
these countries really are or very few
of them are what they do instead is
expel their Islamists and then because
they feel guilty about that and exposed
by that they then empower those left
behind who are just slightly less
violent in many cases and whose ideas
only differ from bin Laden's by degree
until in unless they take on their ideas
and empower others to do so we're never
going to be able to confront bin Laden
ism talk I've met water
excuse me just one second
I'm fine now let me just finish with a
couple of points um people have asked me
um what's the column you got the most
feedback on I should say positive
feedback negative feedback would be hard
to decide but positive feedback since
9/11 and it's very clear to me which
columns and it relates to something I
said earlier I did two columns basically
one was called let's roll and the other
is was called ask not what and they
basically challenged President Bush to
call in the American people after 9/11
to do something hard I mean the message
from the administration was were in a
war go shopping we're in a war let's
party
we're in a war let's cut taxes we're in
a war consume as much energy as you want
ever since 9/11 it has been my view that
President Bush has used all the
incredible energy of the American people
as demonstrated by the willingness to
contribute a billion dollars in a month
basically to the victims the tremendous
energy of people to want to participate
in some way in this war by contributing
to a project of American renewal and
American safety and there is no project
I think would be greater than that than
a project for energy independence and
conservation a project they would have
called on people to turn down their
thermostats a little bit or do what my
wife and I did which was gotten by a
Prius okay which gets 50 miles to the
gallon or have every school in America
buy a solar light bulb for a school in
the developing world that would be sent
to them with the decal of the United
States of America on it so as these kids
grew up they would remember who lit up
their nights I could stand here all
night and think of ideas and we got none
and I believe that was a huge wasted
opportunity I believe President Bush has
basically used the energy of September
11th to take a hard right agenda from
September 10th and drive it into a
September 12th world okay and I
that was a real lost opportunity for the
country um this is administration that
is never given a sister souljah speech
it has never asked its people or anybody
else to do anything hard and I believe
is squandered a tremendous moment and
judging from the reaction I've gotten
from readers I think there's a lot of
Americans who feel that as well let me
close with just one point on the issue
of globalization and I wrote a book on
globalization and um one of the issues
that's been interesting for me and
people have asked me a lot about how
have your views changed since 9/11 and
you know the most interesting thing that
really has struck me in my travels on
this question is um I guess what I've
learned most what is I found most
disturbing is that what I've seen in my
travels is how we have become connected
technologically um to one another so far
ahead of our ability to actually
understand one another and so we've
wired the world we all now hear each
other we can see each other often yet
the frameworks to actually understand
what we're hearing lag far far behind I
I first started thinking about this on a
trip to Indonesia I was meeting with a
group of Indonesian journalists and um
there was a young woman there from the
Far East economic review who suddenly
just went off on a jag on Bill O'Reilly
and of the Fox channel and how much he
detested Bill O'Reilly and um I I said
to her well when you're in America don't
don't watch Bill O'Reilly she said no no
Oh Riley's now in my Jakarta cable
package okay
I'm Bill O'Reilly in the Fox challenge
in her Jakarta cable package and so she
has to listen to his views on Islam and
if she could communicate by email she'd
probably send him her views on Islam and
believe me they would be like ships
passing in the night
so all this wiring of the world instead
of bringing about greater understanding
is actually been lifting the world's
blood pressure we kind of here it's like
we're at a dinner conversation now
everybody shouting at everybody else and
you can't get up from the table you know
um you know you got to hear everything
and what's dangerous about it and this
has been particularly clear to me is um
the way in which the Internet has become
an instrument for passing on and
disseminating some of the most vile
rumors since 9/11 most importantly the
complete lie that 4,000 Jews were warned
not to go to work on the morning of
September 11th that was basically
disseminated on the Internet and what
people don't understand is that the
Internet is an open sewer of untreated
unfiltered information it can make you
smarter faster than any technology I
know and it can make you dumber faster
than any technology I know but
unfortunately people often especially
young people can't discriminate between
the two and people have often said to me
but but but I read it on the Internet as
if that patina of technology somehow can
overcome the fact that it's just an
electronic version of the National
Inquirer in some cases and that problem
I don't know how to heal that problem
but that is a problem and I bumped up
against it in a lot of quarters of the
world um let me just say in in
conclusion that done on that same trip
actually to Indonesia I ran into an
American diplomat who told me that she
had been to Milan in East Java and saw a
young boy there riding a bike and he was
wearing an Osama bin Laden t-shirt and a
New York Yankees baseball cap
Jenna and I didn't see it but I can
believe it because I've seen those kinds
of things in a lot of places around the
world and in a way that young boys
uniform it really captures where a lot
of young people are around the world
today there's an enormous attraction and
pull and envy and appeal visa vie
America and there's a certain revulsion
and also a desire to retain and concern
about one's own olive tree one owns
authenticity one's own roots there's a
tension between that young boy and and
despite what they say they're really
open they can go either way but it's
clear to me what our challenge is in
this year after 9/11 and it's to make
sure he grows into the cap not the
t-shirt thank you very much questions of
we please stand up when you ask your
question and if you're not standing up
for ready Anna and and and Tom Friedman
will repeat the questions go ahead I
agree is what you say about the needs of
the modernization but just the
arab-israeli conflict two Arab leaders
that made peace with Israel were
themselves autocracy it's hard to
imagine
to a vote in either of those two
countries today that they vote for
peacefully on the other hand one
democracy dear Israel is not clear to me
that in a democratic setup that they
would well sit the president yeah that
Israel wouldn't vote for peace that's
not because it's not a democracy that's
because of the political that's because
of the context yeah exactly
well did you all hear the question he
wants to know if I'm going to stay in
sign books afterwards and um absolutely
and bless you for asking
no the question was on the two Arab
leaders who have made peace with Israel
that King Hussein of Jordan and Anwar
Sadat of Egypt weren't Democrats
um but I'm not sure that and so
therefore if you had democracy in these
countries you wouldn't have had peace
but that that's roughly the question but
I - you I'd ask question how do you know
um since who is to say that a
democratically elected government in
those countries wouldn't have made peace
with Israel I don't think that that is
necessarily obvious because maybe one
reason for the rage and hatred that
still boils up in those countries like
Egypt you know which led to Sadat's
death is is because it's not a democracy
so I don't think it's self-evident that
just because the ones who did it were
dictators Democrats could never do it
just the opposite I feel a lot more
comfortable if these pieces were made by
Democrats and not by dictators cuz you
know they might have felt that's
protected by the fact that they had
control of the state and could make
peace against the wishes I'm sorry
yeah I mean there's no question that's
the case I think the more you know
problematic question the one I'm
wrestling with is how do you get from
here to there you know okay you've got
the regimes that you've got how do you
get from from those to something
resembling a democracy because that's a
long process and I think that's one of
the most important questions in
political science today
what is democratization and how do you
do it in every country is really
different but I do think if some what we
have to keep in mind is real democracy
isn't about voting it's about all the
other stuff
it's about rule of law it's about
constitutionalism it's about regulatory
agencies and oversight it's all about
the rights of minorities not about you
know majority rule and it's really they
got to be a gradual process I look to
Thailand and Turkey as as interesting
examples of how you do it basically
where an authoritarian regime gradually
seeds power starting with local
elections regional elections a freer
press in franchising women you know
basically gradually gradually seeding
power but leaving in reserve or holding
in reserve a certain power in the event
that people as they gain power try to
use it in some anti-democratic way this
is a 50 60 year transition and so it's
going to take a long time but you know
the first rule of holes is when you're
in one stop digging and you know right
now we just want to get people to stop
digging and start thinking about some
other things now you know one of the
important things about post 9/11 is that
we've been raising these issues and what
I found in traveling through the urban
Muslim world is that if you ignore the
press and if you ignore sort of the
phony intellectuals and you actually
talk to real people they're talking
about all these issues around their
dinner tables there's a real
conversation going on I don't know where
it's going to go I don't know how long
it's going to last I don't know who will
lead it and I don't know how far it can
go
without more democracy but I tell you
people are talking about these issues
Bahrain is going to have is moving to
become a constitutional monarchy the
smallest you know country there
but and others experimenting morocco is
experimenting these are they'll be
flawed they'll be two steps forward one
step back but at least you see some
people now understanding where they
they've got to go and starting to at
least experiment in that direction so I
don't think all is lost we go back over
here and we'll come back yeah I feel as
though I live in a dictatorship right
now I mean I'm really frightened that
we're I'm really frightened that we're
being pulled into war and I want to know
if you think that's true and secondly
you keep talking about we should meaning
the nation's on it but the nation
doesn't what what do people do probably
react yeah that's it um the lady asked
she feels that she's not living in a
democracy herself that the countries
being um kind of willy-nilly dragged
into a war that no one's voted on and
while one can talk about we should do
this and we should do that it's not
happening we don't have a president
right now who reflects that and you know
those are those are serious issues but I
I'm not going to dodge your question but
let me sort of come at it from from just
like today's paper I mean your friend of
mine said to me last night my friend
does Steve Cohen is one of my sort of
gurus he said you know the bush people
are to foreign policy what Gingrich and
his crowd were to domestic policy okay
and I call it the contract without the
world okay
or or the contract only with America and
I think that's where they're sort of gut
impulse starts you know now when we talk
about Iraq my might and I won't pull my
punches here at all I leaned in favor of
doing something in Iraq I leaned in
favor but only if we can do it right
because I do believe Saddam Hussein is a
really bad guy who is doing really has
done really bad things and will continue
to do them so that's frankly where I
come from but I'm only going to support
it when I hear the case and when I see
how it's made now these guys have done
this complete
ass-backwards they leak their military
plans before the justification for the
war so we had the whole world up in arms
on buffet and then they allowed other
people because they did it that way to
define what their aspirin for them it's
really a wag the dog it's about the
November elections it was completely
loopy the way the way they did it and um
you know why they did it that way I
don't know as as you might realize I'm
not exactly tight with this
administration okay so they don't
confide in me I don't confide in them
and so I don't know why they did it that
way but I think they're paying a huge
price for it now but what struck me I
just got around to reading the post
today on my way here and the front page
is all about you know Bush had to meet
in the White House with the
congressional leaders and basically say
to them I'm going to listen to you and
yeah it's way too late you can say all
of those things but the fact is the
democracy worked at the end of the day
he ain't doing nothing at the end of the
day if the public and the Congress is
against it I really believe that and I
think it's very important for them to
understand there's an enormous hubris
among a certain core of this young boy I
said this is not pushed - this is Reagan
3 ok this is Reagan cubed this is the
undiluted essence and coffee grinds of
the Reagan administration ok this is the
real core ok these guys and there's a
lot of hubris that came with that and
and you really saw you see see we have
the power today to destroy the Taliban
regime in Afghanistan on our own and we
did it on our own without native we have
the power today to destroy Saddam
Hussein's regime in Baghdad on our own
but you know what we don't have the
power for to rebuild Afghanistan on our
own to rebuild Iraq on our own and that
gets to sort of my issues you know I can
see and accept the moral and strategic
argument for taking on Saddam Hussein
but I have several questions I first of
all want it to be debated and approved
by the Congress because this would be I
have a kind of a Pottery Barn view of
foreign policy when it comes to these
things you know you're going to the
Pottery Barn the sign says break it and
you
on it okay well if we break Iraq we own
Iraq if we break Afghanistan we own
Afghanistan
those are big problems to own and if
we're going to take that on and there
are in fact legitimate moral and
strategic arguments for doing it we need
to do it with everybody holding hands
and stepping forward together because
this is a big project and the attempted
assassination of Hamid Karzai today and
the fact that his killers had to be
deterred by who his American security
guards killed his would-be assassins do
you realize the subtle message that sins
that you are now being protected you
know by the Americans and how they can D
legitimize him I truly worried about him
so these are really complicated problems
there are real issues at stake in if
we're going to take it on number one we
need to do it together number two it
seems to me if we're going to take it on
there has got to be a causes Bela
there's got to be a trigger that we
cannot just go at a key rock from a
standing start we got to go back to the
UN offer resolution very clear very
simple unadorned full and complete
inspections anytime anywhere in
accordance with all the 19 previous UN
resolutions on this do you agree or do
you disagree we have to show as which
one did that we will go the extra mile
to find a diplomatic solution because
without that we won't have the allies we
need thirdly we need a war plan that can
work I'm not an expert in that I would
leave that to the experts but I as I
just imagined it I don't know quite how
you do this how you take apart a country
not in the middle of a war not after a
war but from a kind of standing start
this isn't Germany and Japan after World
War two it's not Bosnia and Kosovo in
the throes of a civil war with
everything destroyed and you come in the
middle of it so we need a plan that our
military has confidence can actually do
the job I don't put those out there as
obstacles and when you reach those three
you know when you overcome those three
I'll give you three more the
to me are the serious issues that we
have to debate and be and raise and we
got to approach this problem with
humility okay because I don't know very
much about Iraq and I don't know anyone
who does okay and this is a really
complicated country and what I resent is
people who simply say you haven't signed
up yet
you're an appeaser you're you know
whatever I'm sorry that is that is
really I think truly unbecoming
unhelpful and that's what will drive a
lot of Americans away from this so I
think if the president can make the case
and does make the case and goes through
the exercise of making the case because
if you can't do that for yourself in
your own people then there's usually a
problem you know and so that's really
what I'm waiting for myself to decide
what you know what I what I think about
it
Oh what are the odds of it's going the
way you would like it to go do you think
I don't I don't know I really I think
it's a such a serious question that I
don't want to just freelance on it I
don't I don't know I want to go back
over here yeah and intervention in Iraq
but okay I don't know was it full
parameters would be but if it was
excessive and what be around the region
yeah well what would be the
repercussions around the region if we
were effective in doing this and it's a
really interesting and important
question let's start with you know the
central repercussions because that on
and I'm it might surprise you to me it's
what happens to the price of oil okay
because Iraq today has the capacity to
pump five million barrels of oil a day
it's only pumping a very small amount of
that has it can now do up to two but
it's even doing less than that now if we
got a different regime in Iraq that then
opened the country up to fuller
exploration and the repair of its oil
field and Iraq went up to five million
barrels a day
well that would lessen our dependence on
Saudi Arabia it would also affect the
oil price now to me oil is the heroine
in this whole story
um because it's our addiction to that
oil which prevents us from telling the
truth to these regime we talk about our
special relationship with Saudi we have
a special we have a special deal with
Saudi Arabia and the deal is $1 29 gasp
and we keep the bad guys off your
doorstep that's the relationship we have
with them okay um you know I've never
met an addict who told the truth to his
pusher okay and we have not been telling
the truth you know to these people
because of our addiction to oil now
their addiction to oil their access to
oil is what allows these anti-democratic
regimes to enslave their women basically
prevent them from being part of the
workforce and achieving their full
aspirations and to stay in power you
take away the oil and what happens you
take away the oil they have to drill the
energies and talent and intelligence of
all their people not just their sand
dunes and when you do that I trust me
the veil comes off okay and everybody
gets an opportunity and so that to me
you know is all good news and that's why
the greatest thing we could do is to
wean gradually this part of the world
off of oil we have a New York Times as a
stringer in Iran a really bright woman
who's a dear friend of mine and we're
walking down the street and Tehran a
couple couple years ago now and she's
just said to me out of the blue she said
you know Tom if only we didn't have oil
we could be just like Japan and you know
she understood exactly what the problem
was
you know and so the first impact would
be in that sphere um the second impact
you know it depend again what kind of
regime and what characters it would it
would be a total shock to every one of
those leaders to the Saudi leaders to
the Kuwait ease to the Egyptians it
would be a complete shock and they would
increasingly I think be under pressure
to at least put on a democratic patina
if not some real democratization yeah
well the initial reaction would be to
tighten up but over time you know kind
of all this stuff would would would
or out it could be extremely
destabilizing but I tell you what I feel
okay
this is a region that has been on
vacation from globalization and
democratization since the start okay and
vacation is soon going to be over
because there is a huge population
explosion happening there from Morocco
to the border of India and the real
price of oil is gradually going down and
you know Saudi Arabia musi what's
happened real income I mean per capita
income there's gone from 27,000 in 1981
to 6,000 today and you feel it when
you're there and you feel sorry for
people there you know I think of a
middle-class Saudi dad okay I call him
soccer dad on steroids okay why think of
a middle-class Saudi dad with six girls
none of whom can drive and he can't
afford a chauffeur okay now this is a
real story I mean friends who might tell
me I got this guy's the middle manager
he's not a wealthy man he's got all
girls he can't afford a driver so he's
always leaving work to take one to the
school back to the ballet lesson the
wife's got to go to the shopping center
think I loony that is think of the loss
of productivity
there is no redeeming social value I can
think of you know to justify that but
think of what the distortions that
creates there's a lot of people like
that there's a lot of middle-class
Saudis okay who are really hurting and
this is all bubbling up you know what
I'm really saying is that part of the
world is heading for an explosion it's
going to head for an explosion whether
we push democracy or don't push
democracy because there are too many
young people who know about the world
who are on the internet who want other
things they want the opportunities that
other people have not to give up their
face there is devoted to their face you
know and Islam is ever before but they
don't want to live this way and it's
going to blow I don't know when I don't
know how and the first place it's going
to blow is in Iran yeah all the way back
you
uh him behind units democracy the
bangers link oh by the way Tony
Kornheiser says your your brain Coltrane
that's great thank you plus your heart
yeah you know I grew up in the DC area
and only some years old now and without
democracy they're wondering why people
hated us around the world and everybody
in this room believes in democracy and
dialogue but people that get empowered
have never fought for democracy right we
had a chance in Iran and what did we do
we went for the oil got rid of Mossadegh
me okay we support terrorist regimes in
today right and so he'll be the way they
are foreign policy is so closed off and
then in times of war what do they do
they smash democracy in this country
like they're trying to do today like
they did well we're working to read
scared left to question
you know we win so I answer your
question I think I know what it is
right right yeah got a rich white man
Roger split right yeah I I don't buy
that frankly I mean I think that's a too
pessimistic view you know of America and
American democracy and but I will say
the part of your your critique that I do
buy is the fact that basically what
we've been doing all these years is
treating the Middle East Saudi Arabia
countries like that it's really just a
big gas station and we treat them is
just a big gas station all we cared
about was that when we drove up the gas
was there and the price was cheap we
didn't care what was going on out back
we didn't care who was being repressed
we didn't care what women were being
allowed to do we didn't care what was
being taught in the schools we didn't
care what they were saying even about us
we just didn't care we just cared about
the gas and I think that if there's one
long-term shake out from 9/11 it will be
to change that it's not going to happen
maybe with this administration in 12
months but think of where they've come
you've had the president now give a
couple of speeches and the vice
president I'm just saying where they've
come
I believe me I'm not you know taking
this you know to the bank but for these
guys where they have come in raising
this issue of democracy and reform you
know in religion that's a really
important thing because when it starts
to be said from the bully pulpit or the
presidents of the United States
it really does echo it does have an
effect and so I think see I look at this
last year I look at 9/11 like Pearl
Harbor it's a cliche but it's true it's
the Pearl Harbor of our generation and
so what I measure myself is that was
December 7th 1941 this we're coming up
to December 7 1942 that's all what have
we accomplished in the first year of
what could be a five six or ten year
struggle and I don't think it's been a
terrible year there's so much that needs
to be done so much we haven't done but I
see signals like that of issues that are
now being raised that were never raised
before as a sign of health
so yeah which I think I've been Helen
thank you what did you say this rubbish
on the Internet and you're right what is
your source saying the administration
got an ass backwards and leave the war
plan and have you heard any
congressional leaders call for the
Congress to sacrifice life it's a good
point
sure sure um well let's call for
congressional let's that's damned
congressional leaders as well for that
I'd be I'm not trying to excuse them I
was really sort of focused on the
administration because I think there's
nothing like the President and
congressional leaders can call and do
for a lot of things but it doesn't
really replace the president all I know
about leaks is what I read in the
newspaper
um the question was um how do I know the
administration is leaked the war plans
um and all I know is what I read in the
newspaper quoting Pentagon and and
different officials so I'm just going by
that somebody's leaked them or
somebody's leaked war plans maybe it's
all just a big thing um if it is it's
terrific you know I'm not belittling it
call my belittling ministration the last
one did you want to have that kind of
thing
they are very and on keeping those kinds
of eggs
well I I what are you what do you
administer a shavette eh
one final thing right right right
well I mean let me then clarify because
you asked for a clarification I don't
believe the president the vice president
Rumsfeld or Cheney or Powell leaked this
information although nothing would
surprise me frankly and my experience as
a journalist but I don't believe that
but I do believe that somebody with a
senior enough status to know or think
they knew what was going on that is
within the administration broadly
construed seem to have done it is that
good okay thank you
yeah then I'll come back here not even
fat accounting at the West in terms of
but with you with a Prime Minister of
Israel
what resumed L was really people to do
because that's where you said well give
it back to the US Bank we had the West
Bank in 1967 and it is I destroy as we
like this is insensitive sure um the
question is what would you do right now
if you were the Prime Minister of Israel
given the situation in the neighborhood
um and and here I'm going to tell you
that I'm just not sure anymore
um and I will tell you why everything
right now is so broken between Israelis
and Palestinians that I'm just not sure
where you start to rebuild anything I
believe Israel's dilemma today is that
it cannot stay in the territories and
remain a Jewish democracy because by
2020 there's going to be first of all a
majority of Arabs and Muslims between
the Jordan River and the Mediterranean
and then they're just going to ask for
majority rule okay so I don't believe
Israel can stay there I also believe
Israel cannot leave the territories and
remain a Jewish democracy under the
conditions that exist today and given
what's going on with the Palestinians
that's a real dilemma and my answer for
that dilemma because the only one I can
think of other than just sheer pessimism
and throwing up your hands has been to
call for NATO to take over the West Bank
and Gaza that's what I wrote you know
six months ago I still believe that that
is the only coherent solution a solution
that will get Israel out but in a way
that would not leave Israel completely
exposed to attacks from those other now
you can sit here and we can both sit
here and think of ten different reasons
why that's a bad idea and won't work
okay but I tell you if you think the
status quo is benign or if you think the
status quo isn't maybe a lot more
dangerous than that I would be very
happy to have that discussion with you
but I'm going to tell you this it's a
really hard question I don't have the
answers anymore and if you notice I
can't even write about it anymore
because you know I covered the Middle
East in war for a lot of years and then
I covered it in peace you know for a lot
of years but a Middle East in war after
peace like we've just had
place I've never been before because
what happens in when you have war after
peace and this is what I screamed from
the rooftops at the Palestinians at the
start of this Intifada don't do this
because you will shatter every bit of
confidence that has been built up over
ten years and as a result I got to just
tell you honestly I wish I could give
you a magic cure I'm out of bullets the
the vows has been shattered it's all
over the floor
and I really just don't know what to do
I only know what needs to be done that
Israel for its own safety and integrity
needs to disengage from those areas as
quickly and safely as it can but I can't
tell you I have the answer
oh now you don't you'll get it okay so
let me explain it to you okay I'm not
looking for the Arab world to have
therapy okay and suddenly come to a
resolution that they're going to love
Israel that's not going to happen okay
and if you want to wait for that you can
wait forever and when you wait forever
you're going to wake up one morning and
find that there is an Arab majority
between the Jordan River and the
Mediterranean I'm talking about how
Israel can reconfigure its lines to have
a safer more Jewish more democratic
state I don't really know I'm not
looking for the other side to say I'm
sorry you wait for that you wait forever
one more right there answer questions
and then you can close the state um very
quick ah just we'll just take a couple
more and yeah go ahead
describe the Islamic clerics are the
most anti-modernist among them to be
natural allies of autocratic regimes
yeah
here you also stated that they have a
great need to deport them
and I was certain are the most radical
among them I'm talking about partners I
you know I heard missus uh Sadat right
speak about a month ago and she extol
the virtues of democracy and then in one
sentence had no trouble mentioning that
we absolutely must throw these people in
prison they're too generous yeah so
where's where's the Alliance and where's
the right why are we getting them in
Europe right um the question is um you
know why on the one hand do you say that
they need to throw these bad radical
leaders Muslim clerics out or that they
feel they need to throw them out and at
the same time saying what oh they cut a
deal right well that's very simple
because right yeah right right yeah
there's a very simple question their
official clerics and their unofficial
clerics the guys they're throwing in
jail okay are not guys on the state
payroll these are independent you know
preachers teachers organizers and
radicals there is a state religious
structure that is very much in
partnership with the government there
are people outside that yeah I'm talking
with people outside the structure are
the ones that have been expelled jailed
and the like so there's there's there's
a difference between the two yeah a
young person
if I'm if I'm not mistaken I believe the
second-greatest the country that
contributed the second greatest number
of hijackers under 11th was each other
that country it seems his experiment and
to an extent with democratization defeat
a significant and what do you think on
the second the question was um was
whispered that the second largest number
of hijackers beyond the salaries were
Egyptians and yet Egypt has experimented
with democratization so what do you say
to that is that a fair if Egypt has
experimented with democratization I've
missed that experiment because the last
thing I saw with Egypt and
democratization was President Mubarak is
throwing in jail and sentencing to seven
years in jail a 63 year old Egyptian
American on for one crime only and that
was promoting democratization so afraid
I won't to buy that connection
just a couple more in back yeah carry
the bone of the war in Iraq be more here
too yeah what are you an American
Pinklon Europeans for sample like China
the German champion they can wonder
humble not okay right Iran without us
I just feel afraid or left a lot better
yeah I think it's a really serious
question and the question is you know
how do you feel when European leaders
basically come out and say we don't want
have anything to do with your war with
Saddam Hussein will support you against
Osama bin Laden but not in in that war I
have a lot of different reactions I
think when Gerhard schröder says that he
says it as a friend and he says it as a
pro-american and therefore I take it
really seriously um if it were to come
from you know there are other people out
there in Europe elsewhere in the world
whom I think really are into a kind of
knee-jerk anti Americanism it doesn't
matter where there's Clinton or bush or
Saddam or Osama they really don't care
if we want it it's wrong okay and I
think we also have to disaggregate and
be attentive to the difference between
the two but you know I've kind of been
over the view that there are only three
opposition figures in this country today
and none of them are in the Democratic
Party in this country yeah um that is
they're only three people that really
sort of rattle the Bush administration
and none of them are Democrats one is
Colin Powell one is Tony Blair and a
third is John McCain okay
Tony Blair the prime minister of england
yeah that is I think only those three
guys and where they stand
Blair McCain and Powell are the real
kind of opposition that Bush cares about
because if any of the three of them
really bailed out on this it would have
a resonance around the world and with
the wider public in a way with all due
respect you know that no leader of the
Democratic Party today unfortunately
would have and so I've always said you
know there's three members of the
opposition these three guys so pay
attention to what they have to say and I
think if you listen to all of them what
they've said I think going back to your
question is that while they lean you
know in favor of the moral and strategic
arguments here they have a lot of
reservations of how this is done and how
it's done right and I would put Schroder
you know in that same camp and I think
for all these reasons Bush is going to
have to take very seriously how we go
about this war how we sell it and
produce arguments that are convincing
first and foremost to the American
people you know and and then we'll worry
about the others but I think they're a
long way from doing that yet yeah
I've always understood that the Saudis
and all of the out heavily invested
right what are the financial trading
relations possible what is the what
would be the financial consequences of a
deteriorating relationship between the
United States and Saudi Arabia given the
heavy Saudi investment in this country
I'm not an expert in a subject I and I
don't know the figures and so I don't
want to wing it what I've read in the
paper reports of withdrawals of anywhere
from 200 million dollars to you know 500
million dollars in the wake of the
lawsuit brought against Saudi Arabia and
a bit at the Pentagon you know in a what
is our you know in a multi trillion
dollar economy I don't think it's going
to be decisive in any way frankly but
beyond that I don't know it's a
legitimate question I don't know yeah
oh no no don't get me wrong I don't
think this could happen suddenly at all
I mean the question was really um you
know can you know since it took
Christianity all this time to do this
why do I think Islam can suddenly evolve
a three point 0.1 I don't think it can
happen suddenly at all
I just think today is the first day of
the rest of our lives and we got to
start now so hopefully in 50 years or 75
years or maybe I don't know but all I
know is if you don't if you don't take
the first step you know somebody had to
yeah okay absolutely though I say it's a
legitimate question but this is
unfortunately not like doing a new
version of Microsoft Word oh I take one
more question yeah right there's a
powerful sort of retrograde happening in
each of the world religions
laughter there's trans in both what you
said I'm a daughter of a mommy forever
look I think that's that is also
happening I think there are people
happens limits will have looked at Simon
and dialer and run absolutely
so tried to do this yeah well the whole
superbright movement you know the
violations that are going on these has
these this will have more impact in
terms of how we're going to look at the
world in the net you know in this next
100 years and I heard exactly what more
impact than just out worrying about
whether as long as that again through
this stage of enlightenment the fact is
that there is a great deal happening
which is pulling each of these for a
religion towards a but I think a more
fundamental but of a few
you know let me just try to answer your
question by saying it's a legitimate
point that it's a really a question
about the struggle with in religions all
religions where you have fundamentalist
trends and non fundamentalist trends and
that's that is um that is absolutely
true and and that's struggle going back
to the young lady's question back there
it's still going on today within
Christianity and Judaism okay um
view absolutely yeah no question right
yeah absolutely but but there is a
dominant trend and there is a and there
is a less dominant trend in both I would
argue any of it they're equal trends I
would settle for that within Islam I
would settle for a real struggle over
that issue within Islam in an equal way
yeah I think from outside right and
that's my point now you're you're
absolutely right I and I I agree with
you in my own travels I have come up
with so many to serve so many you know
Muslim friends around the Arab world who
have talked to me about this issue but
the fact that it has to happen outside
and not inside is the whole problem
because only when you have it inside and
then goes outside are you really going
to have a change and so and that's where
democracy is important I got to stop
because I've got I really want to sign
books if I can and I want to thank you
very much
place
[Applause]
Thomas Friedman is author of longitudes
and attitudes published by faire Straus
and Giroux visit SFG books comm for more
information